merci monsieur le Président il est
normal de parler avec la Turquie mais il
est indécent de lui déléguer la gestion
de nos frontières la gestion de notre
droit d'asile en lui promettant de
surcroix une adhésion qui irait à
l'encontre de l'Europe intégrée que nous
voulons si l'Europe veut exister elle
doit assumer ses propres responsabilités
prendre sa part de l'accueil des
réfugiés bien sûr ne pas laisser la
Grèce seule en première ligne les
demandes d'asile de ceux qui sont sur
son territoire faire fonctionner en tant
que de besoin les mécanismes réguli de
réadmission mettre en place des bureaux
gérés par l'Union européenne dans les
pays d'accueil pour enregistrer là-bas
les demandes d'asile les traités et
acceptter ou refuser lié son aide
financière à la Turquie à l'arrêt des
réseaux criminels de passeur et enfin
surveiller et gérer ses propres
frontières en mettant en place un corps
de garde-côte et de garde- frontière je
vous remercie